[الموسيقى]
الأجنبية هي نوع من المزيج بين القوارب
والطائرات التي تنظم قواربهم
لأنها تظل منخفضة فوق الممرات المائية في جميع
الأوقات حصريًا فوق رصيف العمليات المائية
للرسو دائمًا على مسافة
جناحيها من السطح والبقاء فعليًا
أسفل قمة المراكب الشراعية  صاري
ERS الأجنبي وفي هذا النمط من الجناح والأرض
نحصل على كفاءات أفضل لأننا
نطير على وسادة من الهواء و B نحن
دائمًا نطير فوق مدرج وقمنا
بتصميم الهيكل بحيث نتمكن من الهبوط
على الماء  كلما اضطررنا إلى
[موسيقى]
و 180 ميلًا هي العديد من
الطرق الإقليمية المؤلمة اليوم ، كل هذه
الطرق التي يحاول الناس
القيام بها اليوم بالطائرات والسيارات
والمروحيات والقطارات في بعض الأحيان
يمكن الوصول إليها الآن بواسطة الطائرات الشراعية البحرية
الأجنبية
[موسيقى]